somebody who will join our broadcast
position to start the second quarter an
editor's holiday maybe one of the most
underrated guards Mitchell Robinson
express yourself your players at the
summer league so these are rotation guys
missed we want to win this summer league
championship got some guys with
something to prove off the miss by
Jackson the pelicans on the glass
Williamson blocked by Mitchell Robinson
trig Ewing in the national championship
we need to rejected the first three
shots Williamson going reject it that
time it back comes freer but for one
he's been in the league for so long I
don't again he's been in the league for
so long and just being able to
experience things he's always a threat
all the time and to have his motor I
want to have his motor Williamson just
had his three-pointer by Kevin Knox
comes here with bad intentions he is
highly motivated here for Summer League
fresh off of an all rookie and be a snub
Warner three is short Williams with the
board and we'll have David Griffin on
our show rich 15.3 points per game 37%
three-point shooting Knox great time
inside and the flush by Mitchell
Robinson expressed herself Ashley Dunn
he attacks the closeout draws the second
defense the problem is the NBA window to
get a three office so short because the
defenses are so good
Robinson off the bad pass converts a
10-1 he needs to do it here now just
planning the two-man game with Brad
Dacus again a poor pass somehow he gets
a hand on it and puts himself in
position two years guarantee but that's
an investment it's an investment in a
young
that's not played at all in college that
you said the one thing forgiven ox to me
is just finding that consistency right
this is talents there the game comes
easy lob up iron with the left hand
Mitchell Robinson code it does not have
to be on time and on target I mean to
the left hand the touch
I mean honestly from the two prior got
to get Fran Fraschilla we need forever
show nice look underneath by Knox
Cavanaugh and Robinson punching it home
with two fists nine two to Phoenix run
RJ Barrett on the bench and Mitchell
Robinson saying it with his chest
Superman just watch the length right
here mark step out of the way
don't get hurt anybody Mitchell Robinson
coming at your hand
Allen the LOB on target that's the best
delivery he's gotten all night and he
paid it off at the other end or the high
screen makes some eye contact with him
instead on time it's got a grimace on
his face as he comes back the other way
and Robinson with an angry block most
valuable player and defensive player of
the year in the d-league in only 28
games yeah Robinson nice feed from bear
at any lays it in
there's breast Akos driving lobbing it
to Mitchell Robinson nice setup by Braz
Dacus 59 pick in the 2019 draft almost
mister of irrelevant as Mitchell
Robinson gets it to crawl over the rim
and he was fouled job of changing pace
of the game for Hamlin there's a nice
block shot back
Robinson you got to throw it up so he
has a little he shot it in rhythm just
sent a ball go in he's slowing down a
little bit
that ball was double blocked it appeared
by Allen and then by Robinson Robinson
has a mismatch passed up there in a good
look this kid can play this is a really
nice pass the rims there but he has
fantastic hands with the bucket yeah
mark and he threw it only where Robinson
could get it and Robinson made a great
catch because the rim was right there
boy Robinson quick off his feet tends
Aki
to block that shot okay supposed to
angle go to say all right that's fine
he's kicking it back out right but Wow
Robinson nice move with him in Mike
entire don't you think I mean Frank
Frank Vogel mentioned paycock in the end
of this he did
or mitchell Robinson will pogo stick
inside just getting the lane bad things
are gonna happen for you defensively and
when you help up exactly what happened
in Mitchell Robinson make you pay every
time
what's that three blocks now for
Robinson there you go he's already taken
six the New York Knicks with their
highest scoring first half and some
league this year and this living out his
basketball dream it doesn't always have
to be in the NBA rez Dacus likes that
spin move and he timed out Robinson you
like him very much
you take this game translated to yes I
do when you're as talented going
downhill tennis personal as RJ Paradis
for a guy like RJ that's a pretty simple
formula to look at they keep trying to
shoot over come on Robinson just
tempting shooters to shoot it in this
game especially at the defensive end
caught this one
and only fitting that he would be on the
other end and another outstanding player
for Canada my contact yeah Sergei's dad
was growing played at st. John's and
played overseas that allowed Knox to get
the dump or the player to score the
basket Matthews mrs. Robinson on the
other end
Mitchell Robinson with the finish and
they won back in front we play on and
there was virtually no interruption
there
Mitchell Robinson throws Dacus with the
fie Merida's fifth rebound drives hangs
and then tapped in by Robinson
[Applause]
put your shoes back on Phillip Lim is
vaanga tried to follow but Robinson was
there to send it back he was really good
he was a great 1717 and in Robinson with
the flow Knicks looking to run Barrett
feeds Cavanaugh for a kitchen shoot
triple ribbing
[Applause]
if the trailer is running and he isn't
blocked out that's what you get low
management put us in the game let us
play that us learn how to play the
guessing game with the rejection
rejection that one barrel acts as a team
I mean really just beat that up off the
glass what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content